[Applause]
[Music]
it's July
that means fireworks and hot weather and
delicious barbecue on the grill in you
know real life in videogame land we've
got card games and anime crossovers and
shoot-'em-ups sound good to you be sure
to subscribe to get new releases like
these delivered to you every Sunday now
let's get shuffling because when's the
last time you thought about fables pub
games or fable for that matter
let's hit both with fable fortune just
like the RPG it's based on this tactical
card game is all about good versus evil
changing alignments means changing the
powers at your disposal which can
totally turn the tide of battle fable
fortune hits steam early access an xbox
game preview on Tuesday July 4th jumping
in then will net you a fancy founders
pack which includes 20 card packs and
two special cards maybe your friends
aren't into card games that's where
that's you comes into play as you might
be able to guess from the name this ps4
exclusive party game is all about
answering quiz questions with your
friends there are over a thousand
questions here like who'd survived
longest in the wild and who's the worst
chef you can answer for yourself on July
4th and PlayStation Plus subscribers
will be able to download that's you
totally free it's not a proper episode
of new releases without a JRPG in the
mix and this time we've got a crossover
accel world vs. sword art online
combines the two titular franchises into
an action RPG with the unique ground sky
battle system letting your party members
fight at different elevations since it's
a crossover you've got characters from
both series at your disposal and you can
freely switch between them during battle
you can give it a try on ps4 and Vita on
Friday July 7
almost everything you need to know about
this local multiplayer brawler is in the
name
what does SOF stand for well on your
friends you choose a cute little
character jump around and try to drop
Dukey on your opponent's you can play
for points race each other or battle it
out in a one shot one kill mode it all
goes down on steam on the seventh let's
talk about one more colorful steam
release and this time I say colorful
because chroma blast is a twin stick
shooter with a focus on color you've got
30 upgradeable weapons at your disposal
like a green booster that sends you
crashing right through your enemies and
like any good twin stick shooter it has
online leaderboards to chroma blast
launches on Steam on the seventh and
those are the hottest games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change also
don't forget to download the official
game spot now app on iOS and Android to
keep up with all the top stories every
day thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more games next week